about 75 million Americans are facing
another day of extreme heat temperatures
are expected to soar in the 90s for
nearly half of the country and that
includes Boston Baltimore and Charlotte
North Carolina in cities like Albany New
York and Charleston West Virginia it
will feel like triple digits this is the
fifth day of the heatwave more than 90%
of the countries expected to experience
above average temperatures for the next
week Lonnie Quinn needs chief weather
caster var in New York station let's
WCBS is here to put this heatwave in
perspective
Lonnie good morning because it's July so
you should be hot yeah so do we really
have reason to complain well okay we
have a really good strong understanding
that there's a correlation between
climate change and and extreme hot and
extreme cold because remember we just
came out of a year where we had snow and
all kinds of snow in April yeah well
that's what happens in it's all about
the flow of the Jetstream all right
because the Jetstream separates hot air
from cold air ok the cold air is north
of the jet stream the hot air is south
and it flows like like a sine curve okay
like a sideways s and when it Peaks okay
when you get that big Ridge it fills in
with all that warm air well what happens
is in climate change you get higher
peaks and lower valleys it's not like
you just get hot temperatures all the
time you also get the cold cold mm-hm
and that's what we've seen so it's a
long stretch though isn't it five days
oh okay as far as like heat waves in
general yeah I think it depends okay
Washington DC you gotta get over 20 days
to sort of get up into there
record-setting carrier but here in New
York City the law you know we've had 12
days and we were pushing now our fourth
day here in the city and there's more to
come have summers in fact gotten hotter
that's you know without a doubt you take
take a look at these days above 90
degrees now I want to start with you
know Miami Florida which is where the
heat is Miami has had 70 more days since
1970 that the temperature have been
above 90 Austin Texas has had 30 more
days or so where the temperature has
gotten above 100 look at that fact right
there okay you go back to 1970 it was a
rarity for Austin to have a day above
100 degrees now they have 38.5 a year
well a year so it does seem like
something is taking place out there all
right lon
Quinn thanks so much